[Musik]
mit neun jahren verspätung der
hauptstadtflughafen ber es eröffnet
österreich verschärft corona regeln von
20 bis 6 uhr gelten landes werte
ausgangs beschränkungen trauer um sean
connery der legendäre bond darsteller
stirbt im alter von 90 jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und wo
kommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag sport gibt es auch
nachher mit katja strehse ein simulant
es ist vollbracht der neue
hauptstadtflughafen ber ist tatsächlich
eröffnet passend zu den bisherigen
pleiten pech und pannen allerdings
ausgerechnet in einem moment wo ihn
wegen corona kaum einer braucht
eigentlich wäre vor neun jahren
eröffnung gewesen
wegen zahlreicher mängel musste das
permanent verschoben werden die kosten
verdreifachten sich auf 6 milliarden
euro statt der geplanten 1,9 milliarden
wie ist jetzt endlich losging zeigt
nicola albrecht immerhin sie sind
gelungen die ersten beiden landungen auf
dem ber dem hauptstadtflughafen berlin
brandenburg und doch kein grund zur
allgemeinen euphorie bei nieselregen
heißt es touchdown kurz vor dem nächsten
lockdown mitten in der korona pandemie
und damit auch der größten krise der
luftfahrt weniger als 50 geladene gäste
dürfen an der eröffnungszeremonie
teilnehmen
flughafenchef lütke daldrup gibt sich
bemüht optimistisch heute ist kein
historischer tag
die pandemie stellt uns vor neue
herausforderungen und wir werden diese
krise aus meiner wahrnehmung gemeinsam
meistern mit dem start ist der flughafen
schon wieder pleite mehr als sechs
milliarden euro hat er gekostet weitere
800 millionen euro steuergelder sollen
ihnen durch die aktuelle krise bringen
doch davon soll heute nicht die rede
sein die erleichterung dominiert alle
beteiligten
wir haben immer daran geglaubt vor
einigen weil wir daran geglaubt haben
dass brandenburg und berlin dieses
riesen infrastrukturprojekt für eine
gute zukunft brauchen
und deswegen war es für uns immer
wichtig zu diesem projekt zu stehen
die eröffnung zu stören versuchten
zahlreiche demonstranten vor allem
klimaaktivisten der pinguin ihr symbol
für den vogel der am boden bleibt
klimakrise ein neuer riesiger flughafen
aufgemacht wird wo flugverkehr die
klimaschädlichste transport fahrers und
die architektur des br
sie ist schlicht funktional hochwertig
marmor kombiniert mit nussbaumholz ein
blickfang mit treffender symbolik der
magische fliegende teppich er hat viele
löcher kassen während hat die geschichte
dieses flughafens und den ersten flug
heute begleitet kassen kann das noch ein
erfolg werden dieser flughafen jabra
tatsächlich seit dem spatenstich 2006
begleitet dieses projekt für den für das
zdf und da denke ich kann man sagen
allein dieser tag heute der bea ist
eröffnet dieser satz das ist ein großer
erfolg
aber natürlich den flughafen drücken die
finanzen durch corona ist das ganze noch
mal verschärft auch ohne krone wäre
schon schwer gewesen hier geld zu
verdienen
und deswegen ist die große hoffnung hier
dieses flughafens dass man mehr
direktverbindungen mehr
langstreckenflüge bekommt nach asien
nach nordamerika und nach südamerika das
erhofft sich die berliner wirtschaft und
das ist eben die große hoffnung dass
nach corona hier an diesem flughafen
dann auch wirklich was fliegt und sich
dieser flughafen zu einem drehkreuz
entwickeln kann
vielen dank nach berlin kasten wäre ein
riesen fest und keine party aber endlich
eröffnung des flughafens willy brandt in
der zdf- heute- app können sie auch
nachlesen wie es zu den pannen an dem
airport gekommen ist wir schauen auf die
korona lage in deutschland und damit auf
die höchste zahl an neuansteckungen seit
beginn der pandemie innerhalb eines
tages registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 19.000 59 neue
fälle
103 menschen starben mit oder an dem
virus das ist der höchste tageswert seit
mitte mai ab montag gelten wieder
strenge strengere regeln wie es jetzt am
wochenende davor aussieht zeigt julia
schröter der letzte macht das licht aus
so in etwa ist die stimmung gestern
abend auf der hamburger reeperbahn tote
hose auf der feiermeile nur ein paar
unermüdliche geben noch mal gas
ein bisschen auskosten weil danach kann
man so oder so nichts mehr machen
natürlich aber auch sauer sein auch
eigentlich gut weil eigentlich sollte ja
eigentlich zu hause bleiben viele bars
und kneipen haben wegen der sperrstunde
gar nicht erst aufgemacht der teil lockt
dann wirft seine schatten voraus ab
montag wird dir dann alles still stehen
die bundesweit verschärften corona
regeln sollen von den ländern konsequent
kontrolliert werden so die
bundesregierung
die bundespolizei ist selbstverständlich
bereit und auch personell in der lage
die länder zu unterstützen sofern
gewünscht ein ganzes regelpaket damit
die korona zahlen wieder sinken
die situation auf den intensivstationen
nicht aus dem ruder läuft
passiert das doch sollen sich
bundesländer zusammenschließen und
gegenseitig bei der übernahme von
patienten unterstützen
im sogenannten kleeblatt konzept sollen
die länder im norden einen verbund
bilden ebenso wie die im osten und im
südwesten nordrhein westfalen und bayern
wären jeweils eigene grossregionen es
wird gesteuert dass arzt mit arzt
spricht wo der bedarf da ist und wo
freie kapazitäten sind und auch der
transport überregional wird organisiert
aktuell gibt es noch gut 7700 freie
intensivbetten doch diese reserve kann
schnell schrumpfen
innerhalb von zehn tagen hat sich die
zahl der kurve 19 patienten auf intensiv
mit verdoppelt auf heute 1944 allein in
den letzten 24 stunden kamen 105
patienten dazu ähnlich wie deutschland
setzt auch österreich auf strengere
maßnahmen außerdem gelten ab dienstag
nächtliche ausgangsbedingungen
österreich meldet derzeit gut 300 neue
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner über sieben
tage
zum vergleich in deutschland liegt der
wert bei knapp 111 aus wien alexander
von sobeck noch einmal einen stadtbummel
genießen dieses vergnügen wollten sich
heute viele wiener und besucher nicht
entgehen lassen
bevor der nächste lockdown kommt denn
angesichts der explodierenden zahlen der
korona neu infizierten hatten die
meisten damit gerechnet dass österreich
dem beispiel seiner nachbarländer folgt
es ist auf jeden fall nicht das was
passiert weil die zahlen steigen also
irgendwas mir schon passieren
von den lockt dann halte ich überhaupt
nichts also das wird die wirtschaft in
mitteleuropa lahmlegen
und es ist damit keiner geholfen der
hotel- und gaststättenbetrieb wird
heruntergefahren kultur und
sportveranstaltungen untersagt läden
betriebe und schulen will die regierung
bis auf weiteres offen halten
ab dienstag den dritten november 0 uhr
bis ende november wird es zu einem
zweiten lockdown in österreich kommen
wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln dann wird
es zu einer überlastung unserer
intensivmedizinischen kapazitäten auch
in österreich kommen so wie wir das in
anderen ländern schon erlebt haben
am härtesten werden wohl die nächtlichen
ausgangs beschränkungen zwischen 20 uhr
abends und 6 uhr morgens darf dann die
eigene wohnung nur noch aus zwingenden
grund verlassen werden und auch england
steht wohl kurz vor schärferen maßnahmen
nach medienberichten erwägt
premierminister boris johnson das
öffentliche leben wieder stark
einzuschränken
nach offiziellen angaben hat die zahl
der infizierten in großbritannien jetzt
die millionengrenze überschritten
eine für den nachmittag angesetzte
pressekonferenz von johnson ist bereits
mehrfach verschoben worden und soll in
wenigen minuten beginnen
diana zimmermann in london was kommt da
möglicherweise auf die briten zu
hier gehen alle davon aus dass für den
monat november ein weiterer lockdown für
england verkündet wird dass alle zu
hause bleiben sollen
nur die lebensnotwendigen geschäfte
offen bleiben schulen und universitäten
so hören wir sollen wohl geöffnet
bleiben und das führt dazu dass es jetzt
schon wieder kritik gibt das sei
halbherzig denn die infizierten zahlen
seien gerade in diesem alterssegment
besonders hoch tatsache ist johnson wird
strengere maßnahmen ankündigen müssen
denn die zahlen hier sind dramatisch die
düstersten prognosen für den herbst sind
bereits um das vierfache überschritten
heute gab es 22.000 neuinfektionen und
326 tote im allerschlimmsten fall so
heißt es jetzt könnte die zahl der
täglichen todesfälle auf 4000 steigen
es ist also nicht mehr die frage ob es
im herbst zu mehreren zehntausend toten
kommt sondern nur noch zu wie vielen
zehntausend und ein fazit kann man wohl
jetzt schon ziehen das ist dieses dass
die regierung johnson aus den
erfahrungen des frühling nicht gelernt
hat diana zimmermann live aus london
vielen dank aus frankreich wird wieder
eine gewalttat aus einer kirche gemeldet
in lyon schoss ein unbekannter auf einen
orthodoxen priester und verletzte ihn
schwer
laut polizei wollte der aus griechenland
stammende geistliche gerade die
kirchentür schließen als die schüsse
fielen
der täter sei auf der flucht erst am
donnerstag hatte ein mutmaßlicher
islamist in nizza drei menschen in einer
kirche getötet
nach dem schweren erdbeben in der
östlichen ägäis ist die zahl der
todesopfer auf 30 gestiegen und 900
menschen erlitten verletzungen
besonders schlimm hat es die türkische
millionenstadt wie es mir getroffen
noch immer suchen helfer in trümmern
nach überlebenden
und sie haben auch erfolg aus der türkei
brase quetschungen hast du keine oder
und am kopf und bist du auch nicht
verletzt du kannst du mit uns sprechen
wer holt mich hier raus seines klagen
eingehen ja wie sagt der kleine mann
sagen fragt der retter ja lass mich
nicht allein gehen ihm über alles klar
mein name ist johann kurz darauf hatten
sich die rettungskräfte zu dem 15
jährigen vorgearbeitet verarzten ihn
noch unter den trümmern später werden
sie ihn glücklich befreien
im lagezentrum des katastrophenschutzes
in ankara werden rettungsteams aus der
ganzen türkei koordiniert die ganze
nacht über haben sie verletzte gerettet
aus eingestürzten und beschädigten
gebäuden vor allem in der millionen
stadt izmir unser haus adresse
das von unseren nachbarn auch wir haben
auch angst vor nachbeben und wir hoffen
dass es damit bald vorbei ist
viele hatten wegen der nachbeben die
nacht unter freiem himmel verbracht
am morgen zeigen sich an der küste die
schäden durch die flutwelle die das
erdbeben ausgelöst hatte
zehn minuten nach dem beben schaue ich
aufs meer und da war überhaupt kein
wasser mehr
es hatte sich zurückgezogen dann bin ich
hier her gerannt um zu sehen was dann
passiert das wasser kam zurück und
überschwemmte die altstadt in izmir
werden immer noch verschüttete gerettet
es gibt noch hoffnung und noch mehr
arbeit für die krankenhäuser die bereits
voll sind weil auch in der region izmir
die korona zahlen wieder steigen
protestanten in aller welt feiern heute
den reformationstag wegen der korona
pandemie finden die gottesdienste unter
strengen auflagen statt so auch in
wittenberg wo die geschichte der
evangelischen kirche vor gut 500 jahren
begann martin luther hatte 1517 von
wittenberg aus 95 thesen zur kirchlichen
missständen verbreitet und damit die
reformation angestoßen
im sommer erst führten ihn die engländer
wieder zum besten james bond aller
zeiten sean connery stolzer schotte und
längst nicht nur als geheimagent schön
charmant und lässig im alter von 90
jahren ist der schauspieler jetzt
gestorben auf den bahamas im kreis
seiner familie
es waren die frühen 60er jahre
da betrat ein mann die große film bühne
und gewann den kalten krieg sozusagen im
alleingang und die herzen aller frauen
der name ist bond james bond und niemand
darüber sind sich die bond fans bis
heute einig verkörperte den so
überzeugend wie sean connery
zuletzt schaute connery öffentliche
auftritte so rar machte er sich dass bei
einem besuch der us- open- 2017 spontan
applaus aufbrandete als man ihn auf den
rängen entdeckte dabei machte er auch
auf den roten teppichen dieser welt
stets eine gute figur
so sehr dass er noch mit 59 zum sexiest
men alive gewählt wurde
connery nahm das damals eher mit humor
nur wenige tote die sexy sind strass und
widmete sich zunehmend seinem alter
angemessenen rollen als mönch im namen
der rose war es nicht notwendig das
shooter werden der haupthahn mit einem
toupet zu verbergen
einen schottenrock trug der bekennende
schotte ganz bewusst auch als die queen
ihn im jahr 2000 zum ritter schlug einen
oscar hat connery auch erhalten für die
darstellung eines bärbeißigen polizisten
im gangster epos die unbestechlichen
doch in erinnerung bleiben wird er den
meisten wohl als bond als der erste und
wahre james bond
[Applaus]
und jetzt noch zu einer preisträgerin
die schriftstellerin und übersetzerin
elke erb es mit dem georg büchner preis
ausgezeichnet worden
erb seine unverdrossene aufklärerin die
wie keine andere die freiheit und
wendigkeit der gedanken in der sprache
verwirklicht sagt die jury der büchner
preis gilt als bedeutendste literarische
auszeichnung im deutschen sprachraum und
ist mit 50.000 euro dotiert und der
preis für den besten formel 1 fahrer des
tages geht mal wieder an einem mercedes
genau und es ist diesmal nicht lewis
hamilton der das qualifying zum grossen
preis der emiglia romana in imola
italien für sich entscheiden konnte sein
team kollege walter ribot das war heute
eine knappe zehntelsekunde schneller der
beste startplatz bleibt in dieser saison
in den händen von mercedes valtteri
bottas hat sich im internen duell zum
vierten mal gegen lewis hamilton
durchgesetzt er macht damit die wm
zumindest theoretisch noch ein wenig
spannend ich wusste dass ich mich in
meiner letzten runde verbessern und
diese kleinen feinheiten heraus arbeiten
muss sie eine poleposition braucht wenn
man das geschafft hat es ist ein
großartiges gefühl ich habe danach noch
leicht gezittert hat spaß gemacht
entscheidung also in letzter sekunde
weltmeister lewis hamilton fährt
zunächst bestzeit mit einer minute 13,70
sechs sekunden quasi hinter ihm der
finne bord das etwa eine zehntelsekunde
schneller max verstappen im red bull
honda ist dritter angesichts technischer
probleme die ihn im qualifying begleiten
ein gutes ergebnis
sebastian vettel dümpelt im hinteren
mittelfeld startet morgen als
vierzehnter schale klar sein ferrari
konkurrent beginnt sieben plätze vor ihm
spannung in imola beschert nur die
gerüchteküche mit schumachers formel 1
teilnahme 2021 soll im harz ferrari
erfolgen jetzt auf fußball bundesliga
bei der alle spiele ohne zuschauer
stattfinden und das sind die bisherigen
ergebnissen ergebnisse des sechsten
spieltages mats hummels der bvb mann des
spiels schiesst beide tore gegen
bielefeld entstand zwei zu null
die bayern ohne die geschonten
lewandowski und goretzka mit einem 2 1
erfolg in köln frankfurt und bremen
unentschieden eins zu eins meins auch
gegen augsburg sieg und punktlos 1
zu 3 am abend das topspiel der beiden
champions league ist in gladbach und
leipzig erster free tv bilder davon im
aktuellen sportstudio und bereits
gestern schalke stuttgart eins zu eins
die tabelle bayern und dortmund aktuell
punktgleich vorn leipzig kann aber heute
wieder vorbeiziehen
augsburg mit dem sprung von 11 auf vier
bremen und frankfurt unverändert auf
sieben beziehungsweise acht die zweite
hälfte momentan mit hoffenheim und
wolfsburg auf 10 und 11 dahinter bislang
keine veränderungen schalke und mainz
auf den abstiegsrängen alles so liga
heute im aktuellen sportstudio und die
gäste die können sich sehen lassen los
geht's bereits achtung um 22 uhr 20 mit
handball-bundestrainer alfred gislasson
er spricht über die bevorstehende em
qualifikation
und er ist auch da der kult sänger der
toten hosen campino er spricht unter
anderem über seine fußball leidenschaft
und bestimmt noch über vieles mehr
aber singen tut er nicht oder
wahrscheinlich nicht aber er schießt auf
die torwand natürlich also ein hingucker
es steht ein verregneter sonntag bevor
trocken bleibt es höchstens mal im
norden und direkt an den alpen die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um kurz nach
10 im heute journal
hier ist morgen petra gerster dran wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
noch einen fröhlichen samstagabend auch
ohne halloween geister auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
group live zuschauer es kündigt sich
wieder regen an und das auch gut so denn
können wir dringend gebrauchen die
tiefen bodenschichten sind bei uns noch
viel zu trocken und es ist wichtig auch
wenn es jetzt im oktober etwas nasser
war als normal also die nächste
regenfront liegt vor der haustür zieht
jetzt heute nacht über norddeutschland
hinweg nach osten morgen früh folgt
neuer regen aus dem südwesten nach ziel
über deutschland und es bleibt dabei
ziemlich mit heute nacht also erst
einmal der regen der durchzieht nach
osten über norddeutschland hinweg im
süden bleibt es allerdings trocken und
morgen zieht dann ein neues regengebiet
aus dem südwesten richtung elbe es geht
alles sehr schnell
an den küsten ist zunächst noch trocken
auch im süden nachmittags regnet dann
allerdings überall an den küsten
vielleicht nicht ganz so stark und
trocken ist es eigentlich nur direkt an
den alpen
dazu weht dieser kräftige süd bis
südwestwind
es ist relativ mild trotz des regens im
westen sind es 15 bis 19 grad ansonsten
etwa 11 bis 16 grad und am montag wird
es ja noch wärmer im südwesten zum teil
bis zu 23 grad und es wird stürmische
norddeutschland ansonsten haben eine
abkühlung bis zum mittwoch um zehn grad
aber dann scheint wenigstens überall die
sonne
ich wünschen einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut